You know that
the system in Russia,
the Soviet Union,
which was a collection
of states and empire
and the system that mouse established in
China and the system that still exists
in Korea as a remnant of the Cold War
and systems in Southeast Asia and in
Africa were all predicated on Marxist
presuppositions.
MMM
presuppositions that
we're Utopian in nature
and that
posited or Utopian future where property
was held in common and everyone had
enough and everyone was called upon
to do what they could write from each
according to his ability to
each according to his need,
which is a lovely sentiment.
And you can imagine how it would be
attractive even intellectually because of
course,
other systems,
all other systems produce
vast disparities in income.